zart
schmelzend lecker das ist vermutlich das
erste was einem einfällt sobald man an
schokolade denkt wie aber ist es mit
kinderarbeit und der ausbeutung der
kakaobauern daran denken wir kaum oder
mehr als 1,6 millionen kinder arbeiten
auf kakaoplantagen in ghana oder der
elfenbeinküste die beiden länder
produzieren ca 60 prozent des weltweiten
kakaos auch die lieferketten von
deutschland und europa sind betroffen
mussten kinder schuften für meinen
schokoriegel hier dass es zumindest
nicht ausgeschlossen
wenn ich jetzt eigentlich kriminell und
macht man sich mit schokoladen essen
strafbar
ja sagt der journalist der in van der
pütten und hat sich selbst für
schokoladen essen angezeigt
[Musik]
mir wurde bewusst dass ich mich meiner
verantwortung als konsument stellen
musste nachdem ich mit einem professor
für strafrecht gesprochen hatte
beschloss ich mich selbst für den kauf
und verzehr von schokolade anzuklagen
letztendlich hat ihn das gericht
freigesprochen
von der küken hat daraufhin seine eigene
schokoladenmarke gegründet das ziel von
tonis kolonie ist es schokolade ohne
sklaven kinderarbeit herzustellen keine
einfache mission
selbst etablierte
schokoladenhersteller sind bisher
gescheitert an der situation hat sich in
den letzten 20 jahren fast nichts
verändert damals im 2001 wurde das haken
engel protokoll verabschiedet dass ich
industrieweite ziele gesetzt hatte
kinderarbeit aus der kakao industrie zu
eliminieren seitdem wurden sämtliche
deadlines
nicht wirklich getroffen oder sind
seitdem verstrichen und gehen dabei ist
nach wie vor ein sehr großes problem in
der industrie sie nimmt sogar zu und das
trotz wachsender umsätze der
spieleindustrie diese liegen weltweit
bei über 130 milliarden us dollar pro
jahr
warum aber ist es so schwer kinderarbeit
zu beenden
[Musik]
die mehrheit der kakao bauern und
bäuerinnen lebt in armut oder sogar in
extremer armut das führt dazu dass die
bauern auf ihre eigenen kinder als
unbezahlte arbeitskräfte zurückgreifen
weil sie sich schlichtweg eine bezahlte
arbeitskräfte leisten können wenn man
dass kinderarbeit problemen beenden will
dann muss man also auch eine lösung für
das armutsproblem finden
niedrige kakaopreise verschärfen die
armut von dem preis den wir in
deutschland für eine tafel schokolade
ausgeben kommen nur etwa sechs prozent
bei den kakaobauern an im schnitt
verdienen die rund drei millionen bauern
in ghana und elfenbeinküste weniger als
einem dollar am tag und leben damit in
extremer armut
der großteil des verkaufspreises geht an
die schokoladenhersteller und die
supermärkte
ghana und die elfenbeinküste wehren sich
dagegen
beide länder verlangen 400 dollar pro
tonne auf den weltmarktpreis obendrauf
diese initiative finden wir sehr
begrüßenswert damit muss man standgeld
sagen dass die regierung mit dieser
initiative deutlich mehr für die kakao
bauern und bäuerinnen getan haben in der
preisfrage als alle schokoladen
unternehmen und zertifizierer zusammen
allerdings hat die elfenbeinküste die
erzeugerpreise für kakao in diesem jahr
wieder senken müssen der grund der
höherpreisigen cacau hat einige käufer
abgeschreckt außerdem hatte die
nachfrage nach kakao bohnen weltweit
abgenommen eine weitere herausforderung
im kampf gegen kinderarbeit ist die
herkunft der kakaobohne zu erkennen im
endeffekt darum sich zu wissen wo der kv
herkommt und sich mit den problemen vor
ort auch wirklich zu beschäftigen jeder
schokoladenfirma haben trägt die
verantwortung dafür wirklich auch zu
wissen welche probleme existieren und
mit dieser angegangen werden die gute
nachricht es gibt zunehmend programme
gegen kinderarbeit die schlechte sie
erreichen bisher nur 15 prozent der
wertschöpfungskette da bekommt meine
schokolade hier ein ganz bitterer
nachgeschmack